des élèves sont de retour depuis un mois
à l'école des prés verts de saint jean
sur richelieu
j'avais peur quand les enfants ils
viennent vraiment pas simple que ça crée
plus d'accepter puis finalement ils sont
tellement heureux d'aller à l'école que
je suis vraiment content de les avoir
envoyées dans cette école primaire la
moitié des 500 élèves sont retournés en
classe quémener qu'elle même si et des
règles j'aime ça depuis la réouverture
le nombre d'élèves qui reviennent ne
cesse d'augmenter et jean je pense vous
voulez voir un peu comment ça laisse pas
assez les parents étaient peut-être un
peu insécure au départ c'est baulois
tempo cahier chaque fois qu'un nouvel
élève arrive c'est au casse tête pour la
directrice qui ne sait plus où asseoir
les élèves parce qu'on doit toujours en
tout 1 respecter la distanciation social
en classe dans l'école dans les
corridors dans les salles de classe tout
a changé pour leur en disant son école
ni plus que l'été et hip hop en tout cas
mais avant il ya beaucoup d'affaires est
différente et elle peut pas s'approcher
pourrait corriger nos chaux-de-fonds et
nous mêmes c'est corrigé
pas évident pour lui d'être loin de son
professeur de six emmy en classe nous
autres dans notre classe à côté de
chaque bureau des x comme si on reste
toujours à deux mal pire il ya beaucoup
moins de chances qu'on attrape l
économie c s'il est resté à demande de
nos amis qui
parce qu'on n'est pas habitué pour cette
enseignante aussi c'est dur de se tenir
loin de ses élèves
c'est le plus gros manque pour moi les
câlins du matin je cherche une
enseignante qui câline beaucoup donc
c'est sûr que tout ce côté là se disent
il faut qu on soit des petits trucs
qu'on sait des clins d'oeil à c'est vrai
que c'est vraiment la chose la plus
difficile la proximité avec les élèves
dans cette classe de maternelle et
journée de khimki enseignes
habituellement l'éducation physique ne
sont pas simples qui s'est beaucoup
d'adaptations et puis si je me déplace
distribuer du matériel comme en ce
moment là je mets une visière puis la
bunge et un peu de buzz
j'aime faire mon travail mais c'est
pesant toute la gestion d'imaginer le en
maternelle à cinq six ans on se lave les
mains sales humains dans la routine n'y
a plus énormément d'activités concrètes
qui sont réalisés sans rôle dans la cour
d'école pas de ballons pas de jude
équipe
les élèves doivent respecter ici aussi
la règle des 2 m alors on ouvre les
portes on s'en va jouer dehors les
grands espaces ça nous donne un goût de
corée mais non aux cocos abstention l'on
s'éloigne on se distancie on a enlevé le
fun de l'école c'est tout ce qui est le
fun agréable à l'école saint-henri
promettait de rendre ce soir agréable du
mieux qu'on peut
la directrice souhaite que tout revienne
à la normale en septembre et qu'on
laisse tomber la règle des deux mètres
l'a contacté très important pour nos
enfants à mener vous la socialisation
c'est la distanciation 6 on la laisse
tomber je pense qu'on va reprendre
d'ici là tout le côté humain quelle
comme je le disais la l'école primaire
on a un côté enveloppant on prend soin
d'eux et on veut câliner l'on n'est plus
en distance
on s'attend à ce que le ministère de
l'éducation annonce prochainement
scénario choisi pour la rentrée du mois
de septembre
mais déjà le directeur de la santé
publique s'est montré ouvert à assouplir
les règles dans les écoles ici jean
philippe robillard radio canada saint
jean sur richelieu